Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swipe on Sky News
you're watching white on the show this
week 3d revolution the secret to making
movie stars look even more impressive
DIY h2o style find out how this
furniture assembles itself and keeping
order we're rewriting history in our
games review hello and welcome to swipe
this week we're at the prestigious
Shepperton studios some of the
best-known films have scenes that were
shot here from Harry Potter - guardians
of the galaxy and dr. Strangelove but
we're not here to talk about
cinematography this week we're going a
bit deeper we're looking at the props
and the costumes and the technology
making those even more impressive
take a good look at Christian Bale's
helmet and armor as he played Moses in
Exodus gods and Kings we should
concentrate our strength in the center
props like these are said to be getting
more intricate and impressive because of
an unlikely new character in Hollywood
the 3d printer yep this is where some of
the items you spot in blockbuster movies
begin like yep they're all named for the
ease of the engineer we can identify
them by Carol Leo Leo is that from Leo
DiCaprio no process isn't cheap but it's
fast and there's less of a need for
actors to stand around naked in plaster
casts anymore
it's got to the stage now where if you
don't have access to this technology
you're kind of working with one arm tied
behind your back it's so fast we can
print we were printing in the evening on
Friday Saturday and Sunday and supplying
the studio's in Monday morning to go
fitting on straight on to the actors but
before printing designers at a
special-effects workshop use 3d body
scan images of the Stars to model their
outfits once we have the digital file
that is a scan of Christian Bale we can
bring it into an application like this
and we can be pretty sure that we've got
a very accurate representation of his
dimensions and proportions which allows
us then to go ahead and build a very
accurate model of the helmet for example
this file will go off to 3d print and
within a relatively short period of time
we can come back with a prototype ready
for fitting and ready for approval the
process isn't just being used for
prototyping some costumes come straight
off the 3d printer ready to wear this is
the original 3d print that we used for
Chris Pratt's star-lord
helmet for the film guardians of the
galaxy well the movies baddie Koroth
also had the 3d printer treatment the
designer wanted to look on that film of
a kind of armor that you just wouldn't
traditionally be able to make so we
worked quite hard to create a 3d printed
parts that were strong enough that we
could that entire costume could be built
that way those with a close eye on
Hollywood say we'll see
and more 3d printing as the technology
improves further and gets less expensive
for visual effects heavy films like the
Star Wars films that we're making here
in the UK the Marvel films where they
require a lot of props you'll probably
find that the prop the 3d printing area
will become one of the busiest places on
set and I don't think it's too
far-fetched to think that in the future
Star Wars films that stormtroopers will
be wearing 3d printed costumes well
we'll see what Star Wars fans have to
say about that another time now this is
where all the Hollywood stars come to
have their 3d body scans taken looks
like one of the a-listers is already
here now in this room Jack Rothwell
operates the 3d scanner hello Gemma you
must get to meet all the stars I've met
a few yes a few big names we've had
James Bond on the stage oh wow well look
we haven't brought any celebrities with
us today but I wondered if I could
pretend to be a Hollywood actress so
that you can show me how this kind of
works yeah certainly I'm gonna have to
take Beryl off the stage though this is
Beryl indeed we use her to focus the
cameras before the actress turns up so
now it's your turn okay I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to stand as still as
Beryl but I'll try how many cameras do
you have here there's about 100 on this
written they will fire at the same time
but we actually scan in the dark which
means we get capture very accurate
images across all the cameras so and
yeah I'm going to switch the lights off
do I have to stand in a particular poems
if you just stand in the middle
josé's there we go so it's going to be
one big flash and I'll count you in
three two one there we go it's all done
so that's how long you spend with the
a-listers it isn't even enough time to
get much juicy gossip no I don't get
anything are their fears among
traditional prop makers about
potentially losing their jobs because of
the Desai's Asian and 3d printing I
think there are fears I think especially
people who haven't grown up with
computers who who are traditional model
makers prop makers it's a struggle to
incorporate this into a sort of workflow
but the new generation coming through is
going to be much more savvy with
traditional modeling skills and digital
skills and I think it's a really good
combination to have and you'll be a real
successively hold on to those two things
what happens is we put these all
together and a piece of software called
Ashley soft and that combines them into
a 3d model which you can see something
like here here we captured a dynamic
scan a football player well I might not
look as agile as the footballer but it's
good enough to help design my 3d printed
movie costume if I ever needed one
you're watching flight still to come
time to evolve it's monster vs. man in
our games review that is 3d scanner
operator Jack anyway here's a roundup of
some of this week's other tech news
scientists have developed a chair that
assembles itself underwater using
magnets that pull the pieces together in
the right order
the chair is only 15 centimeters high
and the process took around seven hours
the team at Massachusetts Institute of
Technology are demonstrating the idea
can work but there are real-world uses
for the concept including underwater
repairs an app from the US that lets you
breathalyze yourself with police-grade
technology on your smartphone has been
launched in the UK to help you
understand when you're over the limit
alcohol works with the mouthpiece and
also has a taxi app section should you
end up needing it
a Dutch company is working with the
Royal Netherlands Air Force to give a
whole new meaning to the phrase flying
circus aerial robots equipped with
lasers and projectors will perform at
the Amsterdam Arena later this year
billed as the world's first drone circus
it'll apparently offer battles races
illusions and magic now this isn't the
only alien in this week's show there's a
whole lot more in our games review
here's Holly Nielsen the order 1886 is a
cover shooter set in Victorian London we
have little bits of supernatural
elements in there it's incredibly
cinematic it uses wide screen and it has
long cutscenes really good characters
and very well voice acted the guns are
very satisfying to use they're quite
unique however because it's so heavily
scripted when you get a really
interesting weapon you don't really get
much time to explore and learn how to
use it so it's a game that is very
almost great however because of a bit of
repetitive gameplay and because it's
quite short it just holds off and being
brilliant
idea involved is really interesting it's
a five player first-person competitive
shooter you can either play as the
humans you those four of them and there
are four different hunter classes or you
can play as the monster the big enemy
that they're hunting down this is a
really interesting idea that can fit you
as the boss in an enemy fight however it
is a brilliant game when you're playing
with five friends you'll have a mic or
you can all communicate but it is a bit
confusing when you don't know people or
if you can't communicate with a mic it's
very difficult to organize a fight
however if you do have these friends
with the same interest and all a similar
level it is a really great experience
the original gratuitous space battles
was pretty remarkable it was made by one
guy
and sold over a hundred thousand copies
now gratuitous space battles - is
engaged at the moment and I've been
playing a round of it it's still a
little bit rough but it looks like it's
shaping up to be a really interesting
game it is a space management strategy
game so you build your own ships you
fill them with weapons you place on a
map but then you press fight and just
watch the battle unfold it's very
detailed there's lots of stats things to
work out so it's a little difficult to
figure out at first however once you get
it all going it's really interesting and
really addictive so I think there's
definitely want to keep an eye on
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories on sky news for
iPad or smartphone apps sky nice calm
and our YouTube channel see you again
next time bye bye
hmm gotcha ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swipe on Sky News